Like a lot of fans of the SCP Foundation universe,
we’ve often theorized about the coolest Vs battles
we can imagine here on SCP Explained. Whether
it’s warring gods, researchers, or anomalies,
who doesn’t love a good fight? But ever
since we’ve started taking mandatory anger
management counseling after the pudding
cup incident in the Site-19 Break Room,
we’ve decided to reorient our focus a little.
That’s why today, we’re going to
talk about teamwork and friendship.
Namely, which teams, friendships, and alliances
would lead to the deadliest outcomes. Hey, look,
nobody’s perfect, but together, certain anomalous
duos do have the power to be perfectly deadly.
That’s why we’re going to give you a whirlwind
rundown of our ultimate matches made in Hell.
These are the deadliest SCP
combinations we could possibly find!
SCP-096: The Shy Guy &
SCP-035: The Possessive Mask.
We begin with the very duo that inspired
this list. As we all know by this point,
SCP-096 is an indestructible, mindless monster
that is extremely distressed by the idea of
somebody seeing its face. So much so that
it’ll activate the creature’s rage state,
and result in an instant and gruesome death
for everyone involved. And SCP-035 is an evil,
mind-controlling mask that constantly
secretes a corrosive black liquid,
which gradually breaks down the bodies of anyone
wearing it, forcing it to seek out new hosts.
If 096 and 035 entered a symbiotic relationship,
it’d be curtains for the rest of us,
as they enhance each other’s strengths
and neutralize each other’s weaknesses.
096 is unstoppable but mindless, and
035 has a diabolically brilliant mind,
with no permanent body. Wearing 035, 096 would no
longer need to worry about anyone seeing its face.
The body would also regenerate faster
than 035’s corrosive slime could melt it,
resulting in a host that it could presumably
keep forever. With intellect, psychic powers,
and raw strength and speed, there’d truly
be no stopping this horrible abomination.
SCP-106: The Old Man & SCP-303: The Doorman.
These two are the wingmen from hell, working in
tandem to ensure the ultimate combinations of
fear, pain, and suffering. 106, the monstrous Old
Man, is a pure sadist that can walk through walls,
and loves to take his time torturing his hapless
victims with reckless abandon. He’s methodical,
but slow, meaning there’s at least a
chance for escape in the short term.
SCP-303, the Doorman, is a
far more mysterious beast.
He appears behind doors and induces a sense of
paralytic terror within his victims, making them
physically unable to open the door until he
materializes to go mess with somebody else.
Picture this: You’re just chilling in your
bedroom, loving life, when you hear a fizzling
sound. You look up to see that it’s SCP-106,
his grinning face melting through the wall.
Immediately, fight or flight kicks in, but you
know you’re not fighting this guy. However,
running can’t save you this time. You try to make
it to the door, but it’s too late. You’re boxed
in. You can see that freakish, grinning langolier
on the other side, and even with the horror of the
Old Man on your tail, you just cannot summon
the will to overcome the fear and leave.
It’s perfect - For them, at least. As the Old
Man gets to really take his time with you,
knowing that escape was never really an
option, and we’re sure 303 just likes to watch.
SCP-049: The Plague Doctor
& SCP-1765: The Sisters.
A scientific mind can be a wonderful thing
- When it’s used for good. However, when you
apply the cold, scientific methodologies
of a scientist to the pursuit of evil,
you will often find a far greater depravity
than anything summoned up by a violent
barbarian or brute. That’s where this deadly
combo comes into play. The Plague Doctor is a
self-proclaimed man of medical science, intent
on curing The Pestilence whenever he sees it,
but funnily enough, this seems to mostly involve
killing people and turning them into zombies.
The Sisters, similarly, are a group of spectral
reality warpers with strong beliefs that their
twisted games are actually marvelous feats of
science. Like 049, they see themselves as peers
to the SCP Foundation, collecting valuable
data. If ever these so-called scientists got
chatting and decided to compare notes, the result
would be not only a truly terrifying brain trust,
but some of the most twisted and terrifying
experiments that humankind has ever witnessed.
And of course, in their own warped minds, it would
all be done in the service of the greater good.
SCP-682: The Hard to Destroy Reptile
& SCP-058: The Heart of Darkness.
Sometimes, the best way to make a new friend is
through a common interest. Such as just loving
malicious destruction in its purest forms. The
Hard to Destroy Reptile and the Heart of Darkness
both seem to hate pretty much everything except
causing mass chaos, which they’re both extremely
good at. But we think that they could be even
better at it if they were working together.
682 is able to adapt to and reverse any attack
used against it, and tear through Foundation
personnel like a tissue in a paper shredder. 058
takes real joy in trampling, whipping things to
death with its spiked tendrils, and firing
flaming acid out of its scorpion stinger.
Couple this with the fact that both
are pretty much indestructible,
and you’ve got a duo that could really paint the
town red - with everyone else’s blood. Considering
how extremely difficult it is to wrangle even
one of these monsters, the Foundation would
need to deploy everything they have to handle a
dual containment breach. And even then, it’s a
real coin toss as to whether any of them would
even be able to stop this duo of evil monsters.
SCP-173: The Sculpture &
SCP-268: The Cap of Neglect.
Let’s leave team-ups behind for a second
and go back to this video’s roots:
An iconic anomaly with a piece of headgear
that makes them way more dangerous.
In this case, it’s SCP-173, the Sculpture, with
SCP-268, the Cap of Neglect. SCP-173 is the OG,
and it’ll treat your neck like a wishbone
if you don’t give it constant attention.
This is where a certain cursed newsboy
cap comes in: 268 is a cap that basically
makes you impossible to pay attention to, and its
effects only get stronger the longer you wear it.
Eventually, this leads to the
wearer becoming a kind of unperson,
simply impossible to interact with,
even when the cap is taken off.
Of course, while this would be a complete
existential nightmare for a human being
wearing it, it’d be an absolute dream for SCP-173.
After absorbing the Cap of Neglect’s powers, 173
would become a truly unstoppable killing machine.
Only direct and constant attention would be able
to keep 173 paralyzed, so when it’s physically
impossible to pay any kind of attention to it,
it also becomes impossible to stop.
It could snap itself across the globe,
and there’s nothing that
any of us could do about it.
SCP-993: Bobble The Clown & SCP-2030: Laugh Is Fun
Who doesn’t love a good crossover, right?
Remember when you watched cartoons as a kid,
how exciting it’d be when a
crossover special came on,
and you got to see all your favorite characters
from different shows interacting with each other?
That’s why we’re proposing the true TV event of
the century: The Bobble the Clown and Laugh Is Fun
crossover. This pair of anomalous TV shows are
plenty frightening on their own - Bobble being
a clown that makes kids do terrible things, and
Laugh Is Fun being a hidden camera prank show that
makes your worst nightmares real - the two of them
together would make you laugh so hard you scream!
We predict that this laugh riot might turn into an
actual riot. Perhaps, with their combined powers,
they could double their audience, and also
double the sinister effects of their broadcasts.
Needless to say, if ever these two did team
up for this incredible piece of television,
you’d see a notable uptick in
murders wherever it was broadcast.
SCP-4153: It Came from Site-19 &
SCP-701: The Hanged King’s Tragedy
There’s a well-known phrase in the
performing arts, “The show must go on.”
And this is certainly a very nice sentiment,
unless the players are a selection of living
wax mannequins with a major dramatic
streak, and the play is an eldritch
horror that causes chaos and madness
wherever and whenever it’s performed.
That’s right: SCP-4153 is a
selection of living wax thespians
modeled after famous universal movie monsters,
and also iconic character actor Vincent Price,
and while they typically work on the
haunted house circuit, they’d love to
hit the real stage - Even if the heat of the
footlights makes them go a little droopy.
And what would be a better play for
these dramatic unkillable weirdos than
the legendary Carolinian classic, The Hanged
King’s Tragedy? It always brings the house down
into an orgy of terror and bloodshed. Considering
that, unlike most non-anomalous players, SCP-4153
may actually survive their first performance
of the tragedy, they’d be free to perform it
again and again and again, racking up more bodies
each time. But like we said, the show must go on…
SCP-3280: After The Storm & SCP-009: Red Ice.
A wise timelord once said, “Water always wins.”
After all, you can’t even really kill water,
you can only change its form - And even then,
only temporarily. It’ll always come back.
It’s in us and all around us. When water goes
rogue, there’s truly no way of fighting back. It’s
for that reason that SCP-3280, the nightmarish
living water dubbed After the Storm, is so
terrifying. But we know how we could make it even
more dangerous: Mixing it with SCP-009, Red Ice.
This chemically-impossible nightmare converts
into ice crystals as its temperature rises,
meaning that it getting inside a human body is a
death sentence, as it turns into flesh-rending ice
crystals. If you couple the even more deadly
nature of SCP-009 into the frightening speed
and intelligence of SCP-3280, and they reach
their combined goal of entering the water cycle,
then an XK-Class End of the World
Scenario is basically an inevitability.
SCP-5049: Demon Dan’s Discount Homonculus
Depot & SCP-1879: Indoor Salesman.
We’d like to start this entry by pouring
one out for the original Demon Dan.
As fans of our first video on him may recall,
his mysterious demonic superiors blew up his
head after he was captured by the SCP
Foundation to prevent him from giving
up sensitive information. We imagine this kind
of thing happens a lot, and it results in the
Discount Homonculus Depot needing new, go-getting
salesmen to move products and meet quotas.
Enter SCP-1879, the Indoor Salesman, and ultimate
hard bargain driver. He’s underappreciated at
his old job and looking for work. That might
lead to him getting headhunted by SCP-5049,
and with the increased power given to him
by the Demon Lords, his operation will move
from just covering Washington to popping up
anywhere and everywhere - And what’s more,
he might now have a whole new gaggle of
Impish assistants. With that kind of setup,
we can only imagine he’d be a Helluva Boss.
SCP-4666: The Yule Man & SCP-784: Christmas Cheer.
Are you longing for the holidays? Do you wish it
could be Christmas every day? Trust us, you’re
not the only one. Our good friend, the terrifying,
sadistic Yule Man, also wishes for a little more
Christmas - Considering he can only actually
operate during twelve days out of the year.
However, this wouldn’t be the case if he made
himself a new home just outside of SCP-784:
The neighborhood where it really
is Christmas every single day!
Here, it presumably stands to reason
that these two anomalies could form
a terrifying symbiotic relationship, where the
Yule Man could operate on any day of the year,
becoming significantly more dangerous and
taking lives - or worse - whenever he feels
like it. It’s safe to say, if the Yule Man
decided to set up a new grotto in SCP-784,
he’d be the only one experiencing
some Christmas cheer around here…
SCP-076-2: Able & SCP-4955: Knife.
If there are three things that you know about
Able, it’s probably these three things: He’s
got a potentially biblical backstory, he comes
out of a giant stone coffin, and he’s really,
really good with edged weaponry. Able can
actually produce his own blades from thin air,
yanking them out of pocket dimensions
whenever he needs them. But personally,
we think he’d be even more dangerous if he got
his hands on SCP-4955, also known simply as KNIFE.
KNIFE is an interesting anomaly. Initially thought
to have antimemetic properties - Seeing as nobody
except the user is able to acknowledge it, or
anything it does - but the reality is that it
has even more bizarre memetic properties. The
KNIFE forces everyone except the user to play
their part in a huge practical joke where
everybody pretends to not notice the knife
or its actions in order to gaslight the user.
However, if the KNIFE was in Able’s hands,
the joke would definitely be on
them. He’d be the perfect assassin,
cutting down scores of victims while nobody could
even acknowledge that he was the perpetrator.
SCP-001: The Gate Guardian &
SCP-1179: The Centralian Fire Demon.
Friends need to have things in
common to make a friendship work.
After all, common interests are often
the basis for all engaging conversations.
That’s why it stands to reason that the giant,
flaming warrior known as SCP-001 The Gate Guardian
would probably get along famously with the giant,
flaming warrior known as SCP-1179 The Centralian
Fire Demon. This devoted soldier of angelic light
and his new cantankerous balrog buddy would likely
have a lot to say to each other, and become
an almost unstoppable fighting duo together.
They’re both ancient, impossibly large,
with immensely powerful flame-based weaponry
and presumably a fair bit of battle knowledge. It
would take a truly special enemy to take on these
two together and even survive, let alone win!
Between them, they might even stand a chance
against other impossibly large enemies like
The Devourer of Worlds. And, if nothing else,
it would likely be an incredible fight to witness
unfold - Even if you died immediately after.
SCP-2094: Motormouth & SCP-323: Wendigo Skull.
And so we once again return
to this video’s mainstay:
An already powerful anomaly being made far more
dangerous by a piece of anomalous headwear. We
are nothing if not consistent, folks. Admittedly,
SCP-2094, also known by his circus stage name,
Motormouth, isn’t exactly an aggressive
anomaly. He’s a reasonable, chatty guy
who just happens to have an impossibly stretchy
jaw and a seemingly limitless pocket dimension
in his stomach. All good stuff if you’re
in the mood for some bizarre party tricks.
However, this becomes a lot more
sinister if he’s made to wear SCP-323,
also known as the Wendigo Skull. This cursed
skull is imbued with the spirit of the legendary
Algonquin monster known as the Wendigo, a beast so
dangerous that even saying its name can be risky.
In putting on the skull, the wearer is possessed
and descends into a state of violent cannibalism.
Of course, this is bad enough on its
own, but on someone like Motormouth,
where there’s no real ceiling
on what he’s capable of eating,
the skull could force him to devour thousands
of people. He’d go from a charming circus act
to a hungry weapon of mass destruction in no
time, making these two a deadly SCP combination.
SCP-4973: Dead Men & SCP-2419: The Laughing Men.
“Well, well, well, if it isn’t the
consequences of my own actions,”
is probably what the Foundation thought when
first discovering both SCP-4973, the Dead Men,
and SCP-2419, the Laughing Men. That’s because
these two groups have something in common:
They’re the ghoulish remnants of D-Classes
killed under Foundation watch, and now,
in their horrible post-death states, they’ve got
a real ax to grind with their former tormentors.
SCP-4973 are frightening ghosts that get revenge
on the researchers who experimented on them,
and 2419 are a set of laughing physical
abominations that resulted from all the
happy memories being extracted from
D-Class corpses for use in amnestic
production. If these two teamed up, they’d
be a deadly and terrifying anti-Foundation
force that would likely leave mountains of
SCP Foundation corpses lying in their wake.
SCP-507: The Reluctant Dimension
Hopper & SCP-2935: O, Death.
Here’s a not-so-fun fact we’ve all learned in
the past few years: When somebody goes somewhere
they shouldn’t, then brings something
infectious back, it’s bad for everyone.
And nobody goes to more places
he shouldn’t than SCP-507,
also known as the Reluctant Dimension
Hopper. Though in the poor guy’s defense,
he really doesn’t choose where to go, thanks
to his random teleportation ability. However,
if this resulted in a sudden trip to SCP-2935,
an alternate dimension nicknamed O, Death,
it would in turn result in the deadliest
anomalous combination of all time.
You see, 2935 is infected with
the spirit of death itself,
wiping out all life on every
level - Even being the only
being in all recorded realities capable of
instantly and permanently killing SCP-682.
And this spirit of death takes emissaries to
spread it across dimensions, wiping out everyone
as it goes and using Foundation distress signals
to lure in its next unwitting harbinger of death.
The Foundation has blocked off the one physical
entrance to this dimension in our world,
but nothing is stopping 507 from
being reluctantly teleported there.
And when he gets back, believe us, he’ll be
bringing an interesting new friend with him…
And there you have it, folks, the combos
that’ll break you. What was your favorite
deadly combination of SCPs we covered today?
And do you have any ideas for killer combos
that we didn’t cover in this video? Let us
know down in the comments. And remember, kids,
when it comes to dangerous anomalies,
teamwork makes the nightmare work.
Now go check out “Worst Ways to Die - SCP
Edition” and “SCP-999 Tickle Monster VS. the
Most Evil SCPs” for more truly superlative
anomalous experiences from SCP Explained!